hello everyone perry here with another
exclusive collider interview for you and
i'm very excited about this one because
i'm about to speak to someone who is in
two movies this year that I absolutely
love not just saying that she's sitting
next to me ma and book-smart as well
diana silvers welcome to our set here
hello everybody
it is i diana silvers how is your
collider experience been so far because
the first person you got to talk to when
you walked in that door was the one and
only jeff snyder guys what is it like
sitting down with jeff for 40 minutes he
was great
we had a good time he went to NYU as
well and I got to complain about - oh
you did - yeah
British what did you study but today I
was in CAS for journalism yeah my
freshman year roommate she was at CAS
for journalism as well and she loved it
I was very happy with that program did
you're doing what you wanted to do and I
imagine you're doing what you wanted to
do right now because we were talking
about it before to have the movies you
have coming out in a single year where
it's like it's basically you're coming
out here where we don't know a whole lot
about you so I wanted to take the
opportunity to talk a little bit about
your background and how you got to this
year where you had glass book-smart Emma
all come out in one shot
oh yes glass my Chilean girl number two
I really hope that that character
changed everyone's lives she was such an
evil character no actually I was amazing
not to work with James McAvoy and Bruce
Willis like to wish there was like a
sound machine that does like the wound
the clap thank you put that in post no
it was great I mean I worked with pretty
much legends on so far and I mean I'm
like when you start here then that's
like how do you I don't want to go down
here I gotta just like stay at this
level which is hard to do when you work
with such great people so early I get
that I get that it gets in your head but
the thing is it's like you're starting
out with like so much momentum behind
you and I have a whole lot of faith
especially based on Ali performance like
the one you give in my and again not
just saying it cuz you're sitting on the
desk
hardcore rooting for you but I want to
actually NYU thing because to prep for
this interview I was doing a little
research and you dropped out of the
program correct yes I was in the acting
program I left after my freshman year it
just wasn't for me I mean I have friends
who and finished it did all of three
years of their studio and like
absolutely loved it and wouldn't do
change it wouldn't you know take it back
or anything but I don't know I just felt
like a little trapped and I didn't it
just wasn't for me it wasn't and I
wanted to have a more academic education
anyway so I initially left school
because of a family emergency and then
when I booked ma and book-smart and and
then when I did Eve I was like uh I only
have the time to go back right now
although I do value education and I want
to go back at some point you know right
now I'm kind of just riding this wave
and you know see where it takes me it
seems like a good path to be on it we're
constantly talking because people are
always asking us like should I go to
film school if I want to be an actor or
a director and I went to film school and
it worked really well for me but most
certainly not a necessity for everyone I
mean I think with education and school
and all that stuff it's like there's
there's no right or wrong way to be
successful or to do what you want to do
and I think that you know if if you
thrive in in an education in an academic
system or you thrive at film school and
you love it and you're having a good
time
then you stay in film school you go to
film whatever but if you're there you
don't like it and you feel trapped or
you feel stuck and you're unhappy then
you leave film school you know I mean
there's anything we've learned from
other successful actors directors
filmmakers writers etc like not all of
them went to call even college or not
all um even like finished high school I
mean finished high school but at the end
of the day it's like there's no right or
wrong way to do anything and I think you
know as Robert Frost said you go to the
beat of your own drum work with an ad
where when everybody would be like in a
mood or down on set he'd be like guys
we're making a movie and I feel like
I've held on to that forever yeah to
make a movie you're gonna have a good
time doing it and if you're not maybe
you should rethink that yeah and I think
also like
you know with films like ma and
book-smart all of us you know we were
doing these projects not because we were
getting paid a bunch of money to do them
I mean we were doing them because we
were passionate about the work and about
the actors and about the director and I
think when people come together out of a
place with passion and love something
great happens you know and you're doing
it for all the right reasons and you
feel like you found your place and you
feel like you found your calling and I
mean after experiencing sets like that
I only ever want to be doing projects
where I'm like therefore for the project
itself and the people you know it's it's
not about like how much money can I get
on this project it's like no no you're
making this movie because you love
acting and filmmaking
you know I'm flashing back to everything
Olivia Wilde told me and our interview a
couple of days ago and it's just she
really treats everybody around her with
so much respect like we're all in it
together all we want to love doing this
together and I think that's so important
that's how it was with Tate as well you
know we're all about the work and we're
all about the process it's not about the
noise you know it's about being there
with these people you respect and admire
and want to just make good work with so
I was also hearing you tell a story that
you didn't think you did well in an
audition and I was wondering if that was
this audition it was mom yep I went in
and I had my two scenes I was like I got
these down yeah I know this girl and
then they were like okay and for the
third scene and I was like wait what
third scene what are you talking about
it's like you didn't get the third scene
and I was like no oh no it's okay it's
okay like just go outside here's the
third scene you just look it over and
then we'll come back in and I was like
okay great
I can cold-read let's do this thing and
I had a cold read the third scene which
honestly like in hi and said I'm kind of
glad that was the way it went because it
was probably super fresh and raw and
like you could see that I could like
kind of act and take direction and so
yeah I thought I bombed it but I guess I
didn't vomit I don't to spoil anything
but do you remember what the three
scenes work especially when it's a
horror movie I always do wonder do they
put you in a room and put you in one of
the most horrific scenes oh you know it
was none of those it was the ones that
were like mostly deep lit and wait what
is most deeply rooted and talking to the
queen of spoonerisms right now I don't
know
it's the long day no I think I had one
scene where I think it's Erica and I are
fighting it's like that scene where
she's like what are you doing hanging
out this woman's house and I'm like you
don't get it mom
and well I did it better in the movie
I'm promising you guys that was when I
had a cold read and then yes she's like
I don't want you seeing Andy anymore I
was like snot Andy's fault it's not
Andy's fault I'm telling you like it's
not his fault my fault
that was the third scene that I had to
cold rate of course I remember the one I
had to cold read I don't live with other
two and I think one of them was when Oh
is when Michaela his character Haley
comes up to me in the library and it's
like you know you have a cute butt
getting them lunch note that was the
first scene and the second scene was one
with Andy in the van and I think it was
the one I know it was either we were at
school he was asking me out or it was
the one where I was like I don't want to
hang out at malls anymore it was one of
those two scenes so when you're
auditioning with scenes like that do you
know how far this movie is going to push
it with Octavia's character well I
didn't know that she was playing Tsuen
at the time at the time when I first got
this trick I think it was like I we
didn't know who was playing what and I
after I auditioned I got a text from my
manager and he was like he said it's
okay if we tell tell someone like who's
okay that we say your five seven because
Octavia is five three and I was like
what is she in that I went out before
like I don't recall seeing her name in
any of them the emails and he was like
oh she's playing suan and ma and I was
like yes I will be five second be five
six I can just I can like get like boned
removed from my legs you know that's
cool I can method act and like be
smaller because our biggest worry was
always like am I gonna be - Tom I'm a
very tall person and like it's rare when
you're like my height and I'm so tall
that it's like when someone's I'm not as
tall I'm always worried that I'm gonna
be too tall and it's gonna look awkward
on whatever doesn't matter but anyway I
got it anyway
as a short person I can understand
what was it like meeting Octavia for the
first time because like she is just a
big ball of energy and super loving but
I imagine it must have exactly imitating
that's exactly what she was and that's
why it at first I was at first I was
just excited to meet her I was like
woohoo I don't even can't forget the
part like I just get to be in a room
with Octavia Spencer that's that's a
gift in itself and when I walked in she
was like oh my god you're so tall and
beautiful and I was like no I'm like she
thinks I'm beautiful and she was so nice
and encouraging and after we did our
first scene she was like you're such a
great actress and I was like what like
you're you've won an Academy Award like
you're a great actress I'm just like an
NYU dropout at this point and she was
just so encouraging and and generous and
like give and nice to me and she's like
very spunky and fun to be around so I
definitely feel like her energy made me
feel so comfortable and which is why I
think I had one of the best auditions
I've had in the chemistry with hers
because I felt so good about myself and
I felt confident and I felt like I can
do the scene any which way and she would
like it you know so what was it like the
first time you saw her kind of flipped
the MA switch so she's super nice she
has a whole bunch of scenes in this
movie too where she is nice and friendly
and then all of a sudden she just goes
like full mom when she goes full ma I
mean there I think there's a there was
like one moment where I was in the scene
and I was just time like watching her I
was like wow this person is such a good
actress I'm like Dinah you're in the
scene like it your get your act together
you can't just like watch her is not
your working to act I mean she's just
that talented she is such a phenomenal
actress and it's so great that she's you
know she had this opportunity that her
and Tate created this role together for
her to show just how much of a reign she
really has as an actress you know
because I feel like everyone expects her
to a certain role and then he or she is
doing the complete opposite of what we
expect Octavia Spencer to do and killing
it you know pun intended the coolest
thing about some of the I mean you've
worked with so many great people across
the board but when I just isolated to
Octavia and Olivia they are two leading
ladies in Hollywood that aren't just
getting great roles for themselves
they're also making opportunities for
themselves which is super inspiring to
me you know I think that sets a
precedent it's like you know if and
Octavia said this earlier today she's
like my favorite role is that of a
producer because you get to create the
roles for yourself and for others you
know it's like if you if you feel that
you're not playing the role is that you
really want to play then like create it
yourself make it manifest it write it
down write the scrip you know you can
just there's there's not only one role
you play when you're in a you know when
you're naturally not just an actor you
can also there's so many avenues of
filmmaking that I think women right now
are finally saying like I can do it too
and like I should be allowed to do it
too and I think that's I feel lucky that
I get to emerge in a time where you know
there's so many more doors opening up to
all of us and there's so much more
opportunity and as someone who also
wants to you know I I write and I want
to direct eventually and I definitely
want to I want to have you know produce
and all that stuff I'm I feel grateful
that I have these wonderful women to
look up to and like look to for advice
is there a specific genre you're drawn
to because I know you have mine and you
also did one of the into the darks right
oh yeah I love I love a drama I love a
psychological drama I love a romantic
drama I love drama I love the drama no
but really I am I love a period piece my
favorite movie of all time is almost
famous yeah and right after that it's
like The Shining were like the royal
Tenenbaum which is very timeless and
quirky our sort menhir yeah i mean i
love i love film you know Boogie Nights
I love Boogie Nights but really I just I
love any kind of story that strong
storytelling and with with interesting
layered characters like that's what I'm
drawn to and the end of the day there's
all all John Roos can have characters
and roles and storylines within them and
it's it's not about the genre Lee it's
about the the film itself and the
characters in the film
well even thinking about maan book-smart
your roles here I mean they do feel like
very distinct people which is made me
really excited when I went from that one
to this that I couldn't see some of your
range yeah I feel very lucky that I've
been able to play very different
characters and then even an eve which I
got to do with Tate who I pumped yeah
last fall I'm so great eight is like
everything to me
getting to do that which is another very
very different character from Maggie and
hope I just I'm just I feel very lucky
that I've been able to play such
different characters I think it's very
easy for actors to get stuck in one box
and now more than ever there's so much
with all the content being created
there's so many more opportunities for
young actors especially to step out of
their box and play everything you know
and that's kind of what I want to do I
just want to play everything and
anything and everything I like the sound
of that and I like the sound of some of
the movies that you just name drop so it
made me want to do we have Collider
random questions just way cooler
questions some fun stuff I'm curious to
see what you come up with now what TV
show would you love to guest star on the
office if it was like still a thing
I mean it is a thing in my heart forever
so I guess his Steve Carell is like
space space for us show that they're
gonna make I'd want to get West world's
a good pick - hmm what movie do you
quote the most almost famous of course
yeah do you ever go to line rock and
roll's voice that says here I am and
[ __ ] you if you don't understand do you
have a favorite superhero film oh god I
don't
Tony McGuire spider-man ain't kidding
the oje also Black Panther both very
solid answers what film scared you as a
kid The Shining really freaked me out I
saw 106 and left its mark for sure how
this is just my own random question how
do you feel about shining the movie
versus shining the book are you looking
forward to dr. sleep
yeah actually I'm curious to see with
that I haven't heard the book but I want
I should read the book and then you need
to read okay it's so good that's all
right that's what I'm gonna read next
what is the background photo on your
phone oh the one on my lock screen is a
family photo of us when I was I think I
was six or seven all of us in Wyoming
with this like stuffed bear giant
massive bear and then when you unlock my
phone it's a photo of
mom and I when I was seven or eight no
seven I like wanted to be a Disney actor
for like two seconds so we got some head
shots taken and there's one with me and
my mom and then when I went to my first
audition I said I don't like this and I
don't want to do this anymore and I thus
ended my quest to being a Disney actor a
Disney actor how so like it I wanted to
be like a Disney show you know for like
two seconds and I went to like my first
audition I thought it was so like
demeaning but I was like what emoji do
you use the most you know that face
where he's like it's like one big eye
and one lights yeah and he's like mouth
is all yeah yeah do you own any movie or
TV memorabilia yes I own some Star Wars
stuff I have a Star Wars lunch box where
I keep all my receipts for taxes I have
an almost famous pin that says like one
admission to Black Sabbath because you
know there was that concert ticket and I
think Dragon Ball Z stuff like manga
which is really random the follow-up
question to that one is did you steal
anything from these sets
I stole a lighter from books Martin
hopes lighter I took with me and
understand anything from from a lot of
the costume that like that dress that
I'm wearing in that photo that's mine
yeah so you know there was stuff that I
wore that were like personal articles of
clothing like stuff that I wore in high
school that I wanted to bring into the
movie because Megan was great we work
together on costumes but she Lee worked
with me like I mean I don't know how to
work that lease it was like she included
me into yeah costume you collaborate
yeah and so I guess I got to keep those
but they remind anyway so you know I'm a
very sentimental person so if I ever
worked in a movie I'd be stealing things
left I could have oh and in the camera
that we use in MOT the very end that's
my job
oh really that's my house of wine yeah
well they thought cuz I
see a lot of weird cameras and they love
that camera except so old early can we
use that can like that be the camera
that she and I was like sure so yeah I
got to keep that - that's a nice list up
there I like the sound of that I love
everything you're working on really
thank you so much for your time today
and I say my Game of Thrones spoil
yes please game of spoilers start now I
you know who takes the dragon lady chick
her last dragon
that's who takes the throne you're
welcome you guys heard it here you heard
it first that is the end of a dragon Jon
Snow you do not need to watch the end of
Game of Thrones you can just put all
your focus on Gregor and Mark out
Diana's movies because really I do truly
highly recommend them thank you again
here time today a huge congratulations
on everything guys we will see you soon
with more exclusive interviews